das ist ja jemand der kanzler heute
samland und ihnen gewissermaßen indirekt
antwortet frau schwarzer der wirft ihnen
zynismus vor der sagte oder stellt der
kann die rede die frage der kanzler per
twitter heute wirft wirft uns 28
unterzeichnen an dieses briefes zynismus
vor er schreibt heute per twitter von
zionismus und er meint ja ganz offenbar
auch sie r wendet sich nicht direkt an
sie aber er sagt er respektiere jeden
pazifismus und jede haltung aber es
müsste den bürgerinnen und bürgern der
ukraine doch japanisch vorkommen
schreibt er wenn ihnen gesagt werde man
solle sich gegen die putin zu
aggressionen und sie hat er hat er das
ja offenbar verstanden und auch viele
andere ohne waffen verteidigen da einige
aus der zeit gefallen aber lieber herr
weise damit kann kann er uns nicht
meinen weil wir schreiben in unserem
brief sehr explizit es sei richtig und
und verständlich und richtig und zu
begrüßen und zu unterstützen dass die
menschen in der ukraine sich verteidigen
es geht hier lediglich um die grenze
sehr schwierige hofreiter da bin ich
ganz ihrer meinung die sehr schwierige
grenzziehung zwischen der unterstützung
zur verteidigung und lieferung von
waffen die als angriffswaffen verstanden
werden können von helmut in und via
putin zurzeit etwas versteht besteht
bestimmt nicht wir sondern bestimmt er
leider die als angriffswaffen verstanden
werden können und dann würde ich schaue
hier gedacht den genauen zitat der fall
eintreten vor dem vor wenigen tagen der
russische außenminister lavrov gewarnt
hat ja er hat gesagt für ihn er sehe die
gefahr eines konfliktes mit mit
nuklearwaffen als sehr ernst wird sie
das vor schwarzer dass sie genau das
wiedergeben was herr la france empfindet
also wenn er sich dadurch gestört
gefühlt hat dann fühlen sie sich auch
gestört und sagen sie das stimmt und
darauf müssen wir rücksicht nehmen die
schüler weise
wir reden doch hier nicht von meinen
befindlichkeiten auch nicht verrückt
sicht also wenn der russische der
russische außenminister der
außenminister des landes mit dem die
ukraine in diesem kriegerischen konflikt
ist und auf indem wir langsam auch
hinein gleiten
wenn der droht sozusagen müssen wir das
so einfach ernst nehmen denn nicht wir
entscheiden ob der ob der der
angriffsleistung russland eskaliert wird
nicht wir entscheiden das sondern
russland und deswegen müssen wir sehr
genau abwägen gerade auch für die
ukraine
denn die ukraine wird ja das erste land
sein das verschärft getroffen ist also
wissen sie wir reden ja auch über etwas
was die hilfe der bürger in deutschland
so sieht wie wir 28 sehr
unterschiedliche extrem unterschiedliche
unterzeichnen und unterzeichnerin die
meisten von denen kenne ich überhaupt
nicht persönlich was wir 28 befürchten
hier hilft der deutschen bevölkerung
sieht das kritisch unser problem ist
dass die medien überwiegend sehr
einseitig berichten navi auf und führen
genau diese diskussion hier eins gegen
eins und
ich würde gerne sitze ich auch hier und
begrüßen